but first tonight to a political tragedy
now unfolding here in America the
self-immolation of the Democratic Party
is happening the first primary of the
season begins tomorrow in New Hampshire
like all political leaders Democrats in
Washington sought to control the outcome
of this whole process to the degree that
they could and they wrote a detailed
script almost a year ago way back in the
spring they decided that this election
would amount to an Obama restoration by
beating Trump we could all return to the
world before Trump Joe Biden was the
designated leader of this
counter-revolution it's a little hard to
believe now now that you say it out loud
now that Biden is in danger of finishing
fifth tomorrow in New Hampshire but
that's what they really thought that
Biden could do it and they said so right
on TV well he just decided to bypass the
primaries and go right to the main event
and kind of consign everybody else to
the kiddie table that is Joe Biden at
his best that is someone who is
authentic it's the reason he connects
with people today the man who has been a
senator a vice president and a big fan
of aviators he's joining the race the
aviators are back there they are there
are the aviators and he loves this he is
having fun this is not heavy lifting for
for Joe Biden I thought that message day
was very very thrilling to me I thought
it's very American neither was great man
we're glad we saved the tape they wished
we hadn't Biden was gonna win he's got
cool sunglasses aviators just like Steve
McQueen
he's on fire in Fuego everyone else is
at the kiddie table Biden's got this in
the bag
that was their view and then Biden
started running which meant talking not
the usual paid speeches to investor
conferences in Dubai but actual
in-person campaign events well there's
no teleprompter and people can ask you
whatever they want things quickly
collapsed no man has a right to raise a
hand to a woman in anger other than in
self-defense and that's rarely ever
and so we have to just change the
culture period and keep punching at it
and punching at it and punching it I
love this place I look look what's not
to like about Vermont terms of the
beauty of it and what a neat town play
the radio make sure the television
excuse me make sure you have the record
player on at night poor kids are just as
bright and just as towels white kids we
choose science over fiction we choose
truth over facts see the answer to
domestic violence more punching cuz
there just didn't bright as talented as
the white kids are and if you don't
believe me turn on the record player
everyday a new disaster all chronicled
on social media and still the
prognosticators assured us that Joe
Biden was the inevitable winner he had
to be oh but the South Carolina
primaries coming up Biden's got a lock
on african-americans they told us black
people loved him whatever you say cable
news geniuses we just got the new
Quinnipiac poll
it shows Biden dropping 22 points among
black voters in just two weeks Mike
Bloomberg meanwhile mr. stop-and-frisk
he's up 15 points among those same
voters what does it prove it proves that
in politics as in life you'd never
really know better to be honest about
that but of course they never are keep
in mind these people the ones you just
saw get huge salaries to do what to
predict the future yet they're virtually
always wrong frustrating yeah it's
frustrating we still remember when they
were telling us to buy condos in Vegas a
week before the 2008 real estate
collapse on the other hand they're
consistent idiocy and it is consistent
does create a potentially lucrative
investment opportunity for the rest of
us
every time someone on one of these MSNBC
panels you know the Washington Post
editorial writer see index - the retired
CIA analyst across from the former
federal prosecutor in the fake
Democratic strategist who's never run a
campaign that group every time that
group agrees that something momentous is
just about to happen
bet against it and go all-in when you do
take a mortgage out on the house again
get a loan from your brother-in-law in
Boca Raton collect the dimes from under
your couch and send it all to your
broker go long against the consensus on
cable news and you will get rich we
don't know what the future holds
obviously but we can be certain of at
least
one thing in the world when everyone in
Washington says it's true it's not true
the opposite usually is true apparently
Joe Biden hasn't quite figured this out
yet which is why he's still running as
of this hour he's still making candidate
like noises out there on the campaign
trail by turns charming and baffling the
shrinking number of New Hampshire voters
who've come out to see him here's his
latest exchange it's a great question
number one I was a Democratic caucus
yeah Ben Dukakis no you haven't you're a
lying dog face pony-soldiers you said
you are right here now you gotta be
honest I'm gonna be honest with you take
that you lyin dog face pony soldier it's
gonna be hard not to miss Joe Biden when
he drops out in the meantime here's a
line he can use the next time some voter
dares to ask him why he's losing goat
son of a motherless goat you could just
hear Biden saying that hopefully he'll
get to that in South Carolina and Nevada
let's hope though in the end his
political obituaries aren't too mean to
Joe Biden it's not really fair to blame
him for this mess shallow people with
rapidly declining faculty shouldn't be
running for president in the first place
soon probably very soon Biden will be
safely in Florida wearing white knee
socks and enjoying the 4:30 prime rib
special they'll be a lot happier then
but the people who encouraged him to run
despite the evidence and predicted his
victory we should remember their names
they've got no excuse they're not senile
they're just stupid
did we fare though there are still some
voters out there who sincerely believed
Joe Biden can win it all and somehow
their enthusiasm seems even more hurtful
than the attacks of his enemies here's
the latest spasm of Biden support from
New Hampshire
[Applause]
Biden's back all right
ever seen anything saturd in that mmm
not since the last peaches and herb
reunion tour played the Wichita County
Fair
time is the cruelest critic of all by
himself seemed uncertain of what to make
of all the praise he had that vacant
slightly confused look like he'd just
been told to blow out the candles on his
90th birthday cake
none of this amuses Democratic officials
in Washington they know their party is
in danger of not having a nominee at all
by the time the convention arrives
here's the difference most republican
primaries award all or most all
delegates to the winner of the state but
not so on the Democratic side thanks to
changes that Bernie Sanders demanded
after the last election many delegates
are distributed on a proportional basis
on the Democratic side and that means if
there are three or more viable
candidates in the race after Super
Tuesday there will almost certainly be a
brokered convention and a bitter one
that is very bad news for Democrats the
people who thought they ran the
Democratic Party here in Washington are
starting to figure that out and they're
upset this is a certain part of the
Democratic Party that wants us to be a
coach I'm not interested in being in a
coat some people in this country want a
revolution I want disruption you know I
don't know what you know they scream at
people they they go and bully people and
I don't know how you want to watch it at
78 years old stand up screaming a
microphone about the revolution but you
got up and give people an alternative
yeah so at the end you heard what it's
really about their main fear is Bernie
Sanders now rich liberals have put up
with almost any amount of social
engineering in case you haven't noticed
non-binary bathrooms check woke self
abasement fine but they tend to be
completely humorless on the subject of
money especially when it means handing
over some of their money to the people
below them they're not into it at all
they get hysterical they start ranting
about public executions I have my own
views the word socialist and I'll be
glad to tell them share them with you in
private and they go back to the early
1950s I haven't added too
about them I remember the Cold War I
have an attitude towards Castro
I believe if Castro and the Reds had won
the Cold War there were executions in
Central Park and I might have been one
of the ones getting executed and certain
other people would be there cheering
okay so I have a problem with people who
took the other side I don't know who
burning burning supports over these
years I don't know what he means by
Sousa
one week it's Denmark we're gonna be
like Denmark okay that's harmless
that's a basically a capitalist country
with a lot of good social welfare
programs San Marcos I'm pretty clearly
in the Denmark is Santa gory yeah are
you sure how do you know the night stop
Bernie that is the focus right now and
in democratic circles in Washington
that's really all they're thinking about
they fear Bernie more than Trump but the
question is how do they stop him it is
still a democracy after all probably not
with amy klobuchar
so that leaves two former mayors to get
the job done one of a midsize Midwestern
town the other of America's largest city
now a lot of donors in New York and Los
Angeles would rather go with the former
Peabody Judge formerly of South Bend for
one thing he was never a Republican like
Mike Bloomberg but there are questions
about peated Pete Buddha judge the main
one is not can he become president the
main one is is he actually human does he
leave footprints
has he ever cast a shadow where is this
so-called Pete Buddha judge exactly what
he appears to be a corporate hologram
designed by the HR department at Google
for instructional purposes well who
knows but it's possible that AI is now
so sophisticated that we're looking at
our first robotic presidential candidate
you'll notice for example not to be a
conspiracy nut but it's true every word
Buddha judge utters is perfectly
synchronized with the official view from
Silicon Valley and the finance world now
what are the chances of that occurring
in nature this may be the new frontier
and automation ladies and gentlemen the
other candidates clea don't know what to
make of the whole thing
Biden took the first swing it put a
judge in a nasty new television ad when
Joe Biden calls you unaccomplished it
stings when President Obama called on
him Joe Biden helped lead
passage of the Affordable Care Act which
gave health care to 20 million people
and when park-goers called on Pete
Buddha judge he installed decorative
lights under bridges giving citizens of
South Bend colorfully illuminated rivers
under threat of a nuclear Iran Jill
Biden helped to negotiate the Iran deal
and under threat of disappearing pets
Budaj edge negotiated later licensing
regulations on pet ships scanners okay
Joe Biden but can we be honest for one
moment which would you actually rather
have an Iran deal or a chip scanner that
help find your lost dog I mean really
it's interesting question anyway Biden
left it unanswered nevertheless at
Friday's debate the other candidates
followed his lead and pushed a similar
theme watch we have a newcomer in the
White House and look where it got us
I think having some experience we need
people with experience that's why I'm
worried about mayor Pete you need to be
able to go toe to toe with this guy and
take him down on the debate stage or
we're gonna lose unlike some of the
folks up here I don't have 40
billionaires Pete contributing to my
campaign the pharmaceutical industry
coming from Wall Street to do it and I
don't think people who suck up to
billionaires in order to fund their
campaigns oughta do it says the lady who
just got off a private plane the other
day but the whole thing seems a little
unfair if you think about it for a
minute there was Tom Steyer who is
currently suffering through one of the
worst midlife crises in recorded history
he's never been elected to anything and
never will be attacking Peabody Judge
for not being accomplished enough irony
is definitely dead on the other hand so
is people to judge his presidential
campaign no matter what they're claiming
on television but a judge is too fake
he's too unnervingly programmed he's not
gonna win in any way if you looking for
a tiny finance friendly former mayor
we've already got one for you who by the
way has tens of billions of dollars to
spend on the race let's be honest the
Democratic contest as of tonight is now
between Mike Bloomberg and Bernie
Sanders that's a disaster for Democrats
the party can either nominate Bernie and
go full socialist or steal
nomination from Bernie and face some
sort of real Cataclysm at the convention
in Milwaukee and beyond Milwaukee those
are the options either way the
Democratic Party will never be the same
after tomorrow not even close the past
is officially over for the Democrats